we've been testing apple's m1 max for
about two weeks now and so far
we've been totally blown away by the
performance of the m1 chip
which has exceeded my expectations
even though i was the one who was hyping
up apple silicon like
crazy way back since july so
in this video i want to compare the new
m1 mac mini
to the 2020 5k imac to see if the m1
can take the crown of the best bang for
the buck mac
away from the imac back in august
this imac blew us away because in many
cases
it outperformed apple's 5 000 imac pro
and it was so good that we recommended
it to people
even though we knew apple silicon was
coming later in 2020.
we honestly didn't think that the first
generation apple silicon chip
could outperform this crazy imac
so before we put both of these machines
through our full suite of benchmarks and
tests
i want to mention a couple of very
important differences
in terms of the io they both get two
thunderbolt ports
but the imac gets 4 usb 8 ports
the mac mini also gets an hdmi 2.0 port
since it doesn't come with a display
like the imac does
and that's a pretty important difference
because that 5k display built into the
imac
is incredibly good worth about 1300
dollars by itself
but the benefit for the mac mini is that
you get to choose the external display
that you hook up to it as well as the
mouse and the keyboard
which unfortunately aren't included now
moving on to the specs
our m1 mac mini has 16 gigabytes of
unified ram
compared to 64 gigs of ram on the imac
which we installed ourselves for only
250 bucks from amazon
instead of paying a massive 1 000
if you buy the ram directly from apple
our mac mini also comes with the 256 gig
ssd
compared to 512 on the imac so if you
match it up
the price goes up to eleven hundred
dollars compared to two thousand five
hundred and fifty dollars for the imac
if you upgrade the ram yourself now as
we get into our testing
keep that ram difference in mind because
it's going to answer the question
of whether apple's unified memory is
more efficient
than traditional ram getting into cpu
performance with geekbench 5
the m1 has around 38 faster
raw single core performance which is
incredibly impressive
since the 2020 imac held the previous
record in this test
in terms of multi-core the imac is
around 17
faster because it basically packs eight
high performance cores
compared to just four on the m1 getting
into a cpu stress test
cinebench r23 the imac really starts to
shine
being around 54 faster than the m1
because this test fully maxes out the
cpu
for 10 minutes straight compared to
geekbench 5
which averages out a bunch of different
tests however
i do want to point out that the m1 mac
mini was completely silent
during the entire 10 minute cinemas test
while the fans on the imac were fully
maxed out after
only 30 seconds into the test that's
because the imac hit a sustained
temperature
of 97 degrees celsius
not fahrenheit celsius throughout the
entire test
while the m1 mac mini stayed at around
71 degrees celsius
being able to keep itself cool with the
fan being at idle now if you're
wondering how that's possible
you're about to have your mind blowing
the m1 chip ran that test at a sustained
13 watts of power compared to
125 watts of power
on the imac almost 10 times more
and if we take these cinebench scores
and divide them by the wattage
we find that the m1 mac mini got over
six
times the score per watt compared to the
imac
which is absolutely incredible and this
alone should be making intel change
their pants
because apple's just getting started
with their m series of chips
before i get into the graphics i want to
test the speed of the ssds using the
blackmagic disk speed test
and in terms of write speed the mac
mini's 256 gig ssd
was surprisingly faster than the 512 gig
one on the imac
and in terms of the read speed it gets
even better
being around 400 megabytes per second
faster
which is really impressive for a small
drive like that getting into geekbench
5's metal graphics test
the imac destroys the m1 mac mini
by almost 2 times because it of course
comes with a dedicated gpu
testing a more realistic gaming
benchmark the imac was around
73 faster in terms of the fps
which sounds impressive until you hear
just how many watts of power it was
using
to achieve that performance the imax gpu
used 90 watts of power and the
m1's integrated gpu used only 5.6
watts yes you heard that correctly
only 5.6 watts while fully maxed out
converting that into performance per
watt in that test
the m1 mac mini scored 14 fps
per watt while the imac only got 1.5
fps per watt that's 9.3 times
more performance per watt which is
absolutely
bonkers but of course having to use more
power
isn't as big of an issue as it is for
laptops
but it does help with the heat and fan
noise issue
now before i get into the real world
tests like xcode
logic lightroom and final cut i want to
test
out web browsing performance in the
speedometer 2.0 browser benchmark in
safari
the m1 mac mini scored 45 higher
which means that web browsing in general
is gonna be much more snappy on the m1
but on top of that
we've noticed that safari on the new m1
chips is
incredibly efficient in terms of the ram
so you don't need as much as you used to
now for all of you music producers out
there
we tested the new logic pro benchmark
which you can find
on google and the imac was able to run
125 tracks without overloading
compared to 90 tracks on the m1 mac mini
however the m1 was completely silent the
entire time
compared to the fans kicking up quite
loud on the imac
so that could be a deal breaker for a
lot of you music guys out there
now let's get into photo editing with
lightroom classic
which by the way is running under
rosetta 2
on the m1 since it hasn't yet been
updated for apple silicon
in our 50 raw 42 megapixel photo
export test the imac was around 18
faster than the m1 which is a pretty
good advantage
but we also discovered something very
very interesting
in our how much ram for mac video we
made back in august
this exact imac but with only 16 gigs of
ram
took 2 minutes and 51 seconds
which is actually slower than the m1 mac
mini
with 16 gigs of ram this basically shows
that yes
apple's unified memory is in fact more
efficient than traditional ram
since the same 16 gigs is performing
better on the m1 mac mini in this export
test
even though the cpu is quite a bit
slower
as we saw in the cinebench r23 cpu
stress test
the only explanation is that apple's
unified memory
is more efficient even under rosetta 2
which is the most impressive part now
moving on to our
tech xcode benchmark built for us by
maxim erimenko
which he's recently updated for apple
silicon this is where it starts to get
very interesting for the first time in
this video
the m1 mac mini outperforms the imac
while having four times less ram
finishing the build in 120 seconds
while being completely silent compared
to 136 seconds on the imac
with the fans basically maxed out for
most of the test
this is extremely impressive and this
shows that xcode programmers
can safely sell their old intel max
to not only get better performance with
the m1 but
get a completely silent machine and
excellent battery life if you choose to
go with one of the
m1 macbooks now what i'm curious to find
out is if this m1 mac mini will
outperform
our 12 core 15 000 mac pro in this xcode
test
so if you're curious about that go ahead
and subscribe right now
because we're going to be working on
that video very soon now let's get into
video editing with
final cut pro in the 5k bruce x
benchmark which relies
heavily on raw graphics power the imac
was around 50 percent
faster than the m1 however
in our five-minute 4k h.264 export test
which is the most common format that
youtubers use
the imac was just five seconds faster
than the m1 mac mini which we didn't
expect
considering the result we got in bruce x
moving on to our one minute hevc
stabilization test the m1 mac mini
surprisingly finished the test in the
same exact
9 seconds and that's because apple put a
huge focus
on hevc hardware accelerators in the m1
those new decoders allow it to
absolutely rip through
hevc footage in both playback and
export times for example canon's new r5
camera
has a crazy 10 bit 422 hevc format
that is tough to edit on most computers
but the m1 mac mini
played it back at a perfect 30 fps
while the imac dropped a bunch of frames
during playback
and when exporting a 5 minute clip of
this crazy r5 footage
the m1 mac mini finished in just 3
minutes compared to 6 minutes and 15
seconds
on the imac which is incredible now
because
this footage is so tough or at least it
used to be
before the m1 people usually transcode
it into prores
so we tested that as well transcoding 30
minutes of this footage took only 13
minutes on the m1
compared to 37 minutes and 30 seconds on
the imac
that's over three times longer which is
absolutely bonkers
taking it even further we tested out the
even more tough
4k 60fps version of this footage and the
m1 mac mini played it back
perfectly which we weren't expecting at
all
because the imac couldn't even handle
the 30fps clip
so basically what i'm trying to say here
is that if you edit common 4k
h.264 or hevc footage
the new m1 chip is not just good enough
it's now the prime choice because of all
the other advantages you get with the m1
like the cool and silent operation and
this
finally brings us to the hardcore video
editing
starting with 4.5 k redraw footage
neither the m1 mac or the imac can play
this footage back perfectly but in terms
of exporting a 5 minute clip
the imac was more than twice as fast
because
it fully relies on raw graphics power
and the imac
simply has more of it and we saw
basically the same story with 8k redraw
as well with the imac around twice as
fast as the m1
so we can safely say that for the time
being people who are editing raw footage
or doing heavy effects
are much better off sticking with an
intel imac as long as it has a high
performance
dedicated gpu so with all of that
testing out of the way
i want to finish off with some
conclusions that we can pull from this
comparison
the fact that a 900 m1 mac mini is
trading blows
with a 2 50 imac
that was just released three months ago
is simply incredible
and it's doing it with four times less
ram which proves the point that apple's
unified memory
is in fact more efficient like we saw in
the photo editing test
when comparing 16 gigs of ram on both
machines
logic pro performance wasn't quite as
good but even 90 tracks is more than
what most people will be running
and the m1 ran them while being
completely silent
which was a trend that i noticed
throughout this entire video
and it makes sense because of the
incredibly low
wattage the m1 chip uses only 13 watts
for the cpu
and 5.6 watts for the gpu now xcode
performance on the m1 was amazing
defying all odds and beating the imac
while having much less raw cpu power and
even
web browsing performance was
significantly better
and in terms of video editing in final
cut pro
the m1 basically matched or outperformed
the most expensive imac
in the most common formats that people
shoot and edit hardcore raw footage
and gaming performance were the only use
cases where the m1 chip
is not a great choice but if you're not
into either of those things
i can safely say that the m1 mac mini is
by far the much better purchase if you
factor in the price
the low temps and the silent operation
yes software support isn't perfect right
now
but it's only been two weeks and we've
already seen an
overwhelming amount of improvements
which is very reassuring and perhaps the
best part
is knowing that this is just the
beginning
the crazy performance per watt that we
just witnessed in this video
shows us that apple has a massive
arsenal of performance
that they can unleash in future higher
end
max starting with the rumored 12 core
m1x
that we should be seeing next year so to
finish off this video
i want to say that even though i had
incredibly high expectations
i wasn't expecting the first m1 chip
to perform this well compared to such an
expensive
imac but as you just saw it's actually
a much better choice in terms of overall
value
if you don't need that 5k display so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle about to subscribe
because we just got the best amd ryzen
laptop in our office
and we're about to compare it to the m1
macbook pro
and be sure to check out those two
videos right over there
and we will see you in that next video